Україна будуватиме вужчі дороги - щоб зробити їх безпечнішими.
Вже з першого вересня під час реконструкції старих автошляхів
та проектування нових, почнуть діяти нові Державні будівельні стандарти.
З подекуди майже чотирьох метрів смуги на українських дорогах
звузять до 2,75 метрів на житлових вулицях
та 3,5 метрів - на магістралях.
Причину змін у міністерстві регіонального розвитку України
пояснили європейською практикою,
коли дороги з меншою шириною смуг спонукають водіїв
їхати обережніше та повільніше,
що призводить до меншої кількості аварій в ЄС.
За даними експертів з World Research Institute
існує чітка залежність між шириною смуг у містах,
швидкістю руху та рівнем небезпеки.
Так, найризикованіше їздити дорогами, ширшими
за 3 метри 60 сантиметрів.
Такі, приміром, як у Пекіні, Форталезі або Ченнаї,
де на сто тисяч населення в ДТП гине близько 20 і більше людей.
Трохи вужчі вулиці Нью-Йорка, Сан-Паулу або Нью-Делі.
Відповідно тут дещо безпечніше:
від шести до дванадцяти смертей у ДТП
на сто тисяч населення. А найбезпечнішими
вважаються ще вужчі дороги Амстердама, Берліна,
Парижа, Токіо та Торонто: на них гине
не більше трьох людей на сто тисяч населення.
Дослідники пояснюють це тим, що широкі дороги
генерують не тільки більше трафіку, але й більше смертельних аварій,
бо дають змогу водіям розганятися.
Натомість статистика показала, що незначне звуження
не сильно ускладнює міський рух:
пропускна здатність смуги в 3 метри
становить 93 відсотки
від показників смуги в 3 метри 60 сантиметрів .
А зменшення швидкості лише на півтора кілометра на годину
на міських вулицях -  це мінус шість відсотків смертності в ДТП.
Звісно, ширина смуг - далеко не єдиний фактор,
який впливає на безпеку дорожнього руху.
Серед інших чинників: якість доріг, контроль швидкості,
контроль тверезості водіїв та технічного стану автомобілів,
підвищення рівня свідомості водіїв та пішоходів тощо.
Європейські стандарти безпеки дорожнього руху
справді передбачають зменшення швидкості автівок -
і не лише правилами дорожнього руху і
автоматизацією контролю, але й "примусово",
за рахунок звуження автодоріг, додаткових кругових розв'язок,
острівців безпеки, а також поворотів,
підйомів та спусків під гострішим кутом.
Все це змушує водіїв їздити обережніше,
частіше скидати швідкість,
а отже - зменшує аварійність та смертність на дорогах.
У такої політики є й критики, які заявляють,
що сучасні європейські дороги -
завузькі для великогабаритного транспорту,
приміром для автобусів чи популярних нині позашляховиків.
Але поки що єдина країна Європи, яка розмірковує про те,
щоб розширити свої дорожні смуги - це Швейцарія.